welcome back to New rockstars I'm Wendy
Van landingham and after watching across
the spiderverse you might have some
questions about Miguel O'Hara's origin
story how he got his powers and what
exactly those powers do the dude's got
vampire fangs what else is he hiding
behind that form-fitting Spidey suit it
turns out that atsv barely scratched the
surface of all of Miguel's superhuman
abilities so today I'm taking you on a
deep dive through the comics to explain
his powers Miguel O'Hara hails from
earth928 and his story kicks off in the
future world of 2099 originally
introduced in a two-page teaser spread
in The Amazing Spider-Man number 365 in
1992. Miguel's first official appearance
was in his own comic series Spider-Man
2099 in issue number one we get the
lowdown on Miguel's origin story when he
recounts the tale to the journal feature
of Lila his virtual assistant Lila
stands for lyrate life form
approximation and she's capable of
mimicking human emotions projecting
Holograms recreating crime scenes and
storing Miguel's most private thoughts
she can contact Miguel in any timeline
lock into a specific person's life
readings and awaken Miguel from
unconsciousness Lila has similar powers
and across the spider-verse most notably
her abilities to replay events in 3D
space and communicate across realities
in the film her AI is Advanced enough to
figure out spot's travel patterns that
he only jumps to universes that have an
alchemax she also monitors and
pre-detects Canon events her scanners
can even detect dark matter and identify
individuals then track them through the
Multiverse basically she can monitor the
Multiverse on a molecular level this
capability of her processing power
probably isn't infinite but her
algorithms are so thorough that they
might as well be in Spider-Man 2099
number one Miguel tells Lila about the
Fateful events that led to his superhero
Dem working as an engineer and top
geneticist for the alchemax corporation
Miguel haiki hated his boss Tyler Stone
and thought that he and his supervisor
Aaron Delgado were big dumb idiots for
running dangerous scientific experiments
on actual human beings obviously he was
totally right and their human trial on a
man named Mr Sims went her terrifically
wrong Mr Sims hoped that by allowing
alcamax to imprint another subject's
genetic code into his human physiology
he would stall the process of getting
weaker with age intending to give him
super strength Miguel Tyler and Aaron
used their fancy Science Tech to imprint
on sims's genes instead Sims morphs into
a horrific demadog looking monster and
dies shortly afterwards outraged Miguel
tries to quit his gig at alcamax but his
boss pulls out all the stops to get him
to reconsider not only does this a-hole
insist on whitewashing Miguel's Name by
calling him Mike Tyler doses his
cocktail with a highly addictive drug
called The Rapture and Rapture is no
joke you get hooked for Life the very
first time you use it and the withdrawal
is apparently Agony to experience Tyler
believes that by getting Miguel hooked
on drugs his star geneticists will be
forced to remain at the company in order
to get his fix alcamax is conveniently
the only legal distributor of the drug
and that's just expensive so Miguel
wouldn't have any other choice but to
surrender to its Leader's questionable
decisions terrified of spending the rest
of his life hopelessly addicted to
Rapture Miguel decides to take matters
into his own hands he breaks into the
lab at alcamax and uses his own genetic
code Baseline to imprint hoping that the
splice will revert his body chemistry to
its pre-rapture form unfortunately that
other a-hole Aaron burst into sabotage
his experiment he amps up all the
equipment to 11. inserts spider jeans
and blasts Miguel with the machine's
full power miraculously Miguel survives
the experiment but comes out of it with
some quirks when he reveals himself to
Aaron he sprouted fangs and super sharp
talons on his toes and thingies he
actually accidentally drops his former
supervisor to his death in the middle of
trying to save him because his claws
rips straight through Aaron's arms
unable to cope with his new freakish
existence Miguel initially tries to kill
himself but realizes that he doesn't
want to die and saves himself with his
cool new Toes by digging them into the
side of the building he later learns
that his Talons retract when they come
into contact with his own skin
preventing him from hurting himself a
Nifty feature considering that his
manicure is capable of slicing through
guns swords and even Venom 2099's arm
his character in atsv can also retract
his claws by the looks of it as for the
fangs despite being called a vampire
they're more like spider fangs we learn
in the comics that Miguel's fangs are
capable of paralyzing foes the paralytic
potency is so strong it can even
paralyze a giant although we don't see
him utilize these bad boys to immobilize
anyone and across the spider verse he
does try to get a bite on vulture before
the NYPD gets in the way in the comics
when Alco Max's private police force
public eye tries to capture Miguel he
narrowly escapes by hitching a ride on a
hand glider flown by one of the members
of the Church of Thor when the thorite
gets a little too excited about meeting
Spider-Man the two crash land and Thor's
follower gives Miguel the tattered
remains of the glider to Fashion into a
mass interestingly in Issue 5 it's
revealed that Miguel's mask is actually
webbed onto his face so that none of his
adversaries can yank it off to spill the
beans on his secret identity a lot of
people ask me how I'm able to stay
focused researching all these videos and
honestly it's this
one shot Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everybody really they make energy
choose and Focus Shoes the focus shoes
are my go-to but it just depends on what
you need each energy has 75 milligrams
of pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional nootropics to give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew Focus Shoes now
available in limited edition new
Rockstar's theme packaging really help
me concentrate and give me a natural
boost of energy with BCD and E vitamins
less zinc to help with immune system
support and the amino acid tyrosine both
Energy Chews and focus shoes are a
plant-based naturally sweetened and
designed to give you the energy and
focus you need without a bunch of
fillers and chemicals get started with
one shot energy today by going to one
shotenergy.com new rockstars for 10 off
your order Miguel's costume Origins are
really cool overall not only does he
have sick Wings made from thorite glider
fabric allowing him to soar without
falling to his death due to their webbed
airfoil design his actual suit is made
out of a dia de los muertos costume
composed of unstable molecules unstable
molecule fabric is the same stuff Reed
Richards invented to keep up with the
Fantastic Four's unique fashion needs
the unstable molecules make Miguel's
suit nearly indestructible as he
explains to Lila in issue 4. in several
future issues we get to see firsthand
how strong that suit actually is not
only is it impervious to shotguns and
regular bullets it's also acid proof
against chemicals that would normally
melt a person's clothing and skin
straight off he eventually upgrades the
suit to interweave Kevlar with the
unstable molecule fabric making for an
even stronger mesh thanks to Parker
Industries he also gets a major upgrade
boot rocket thrusters a gliding system
thermal vision a spider Tracer to track
the location of spider folk explosive
spider saucers and a self-move it's not
true invisibility but as long as no
one's inspecting it too close the
chameleon-like circuit does the job it's
interesting to see what features were
adapted for across the spiderverse in
atsv Miguel's suit has a retractable
cape nanotech and lasers slice through
matter like in the comics the suit also
has an updated version of a mesh web
glider that helps him soar through the
air when miles short circuits Miguel's
suit with his Venom strike we learned
that instead of being composed out of
unstable molecule fabric it likely
contains heavy electronic and nanotech
components much like the Stark and
wakanda in Tech we've grown accustomed
to in the MCU we also find out that his
suit is Advanced enough that it can
regenerate fairly quickly one super
notable change is Miguel's webs which
are depicted as laser tech in the film
in the comics Miguel discovers his
powers one by one by fighting his way
through bad guys and teaching himself
new skills during a battle with Alco
Max's cyborg Bounty Hunter Venture
Miguel realizes that he has a set of
spinnerets in his forearms that produce
their own webbing that's right comic
book Miguel has organic webbing Toby
McGuire style oh yeah
another notable difference that sets
comic Miguel aparts from most other
Spider-Man is a Spider Sense he doesn't
have one we actually see that his film
counterpart is also lacking a Miguel
tingle when paper vulture sneaks up
behind him but this doesn't mean that
Miguel has zero heightened awareness due
to his new spider genes he experiences
light sensitivity but to make up for it
his long distance vision and night
vision are off the charts Miguel himself
also has super strength which he
discovers when he finds out that he's
able to lift an entire hover car in the
comics we even get to see him go head to
head with Thor and mjolnir successfully
blocking their strikes against him while
on the subject of mjolnir Miguel is
actually capable of lifting the hammer
kind of hard to believe that the atsv
version is just as worthy if his suit's
protections weren't enough Miguel is
ridiculously durable in a fight in the
comics he survives concrete being thrown
it in and even recovers after a building
collapses on top of him when he gets
punched out of a high-rise window by the
thing it barely phases him and although
miles Venom strike does slow him down in
atsv like I mentioned earlier but Miguel
physically recovers in time to chase
that kid all the way to the go home
machine room like Gwen Stacy Miguel
O'Hara possesses acrobatic agility
talents seen in the movie when they
first work together to take down vulture
in the comics he's able to dodge and
weave through bullets immediately after
the experiment and after his suit
upgrades postage of Voltron he's even
able to land a few blows against
superior Spider-Man also in atsv we see
more of Miguel's Advanced Tech like the
spider surveillance drone the Gwen uses
to monitor the spot when she's in 1610
plus remember the laser suit blade I
mentioned it turns out that that thing
can slice a multiversal hole into a
different reality although I suspect he
might only be able to do this when
exiting multiversal Subspace because he
does use his Nifty Multiverse traveling
watch to start that multi-dimensional
journal initially these are just a few
examples of how powerful Miguel is but I
want to know if you guys have any
favorite memories of him using them to
kick ass in the comics there's a
non-zero chance that Sony will
incorporate some of these other powers
into the next spider-verse film and I'm
stoked to see which ones they choose to
Showcase follow me on Instagram and
Twitter Whitney puppy following a
rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]